prestance voix éraillée à la tom waits
humour décalé trois qualités qui résume
bien l'univers d'arnaud après 40 ans de
scène ce rockeur belge a toujours la
flamme pour lui musique et traque font
partie de sa vie d'artiste
je sais pas je vis avec ce en dépit d
annie cordy c'est une partie de moi même
mais c'est la vraie aline je suis accro
c'est une drogue que la dire que l'être
humain fait lui-même c'est gratuit et je
suis accro il ya des gens qui sont
accros à l'alcool loi de cigarettes ou
de cocaïne ou n'importe quoi moi je suis
accro à ça j'ai enfin de tourner parce
que non surtout que je dois faire c'est
fait de la musique avec visible et je
voyage je suis en vacances quoi avec
nous tous que j'aime bien c'est un point
c'est de la chance
puma
c'est sur un air du king que sa passion
pour la musique est née très jeune je me
souviens j'étais huit ans et j'ai j'ai
un copain il y deux seuls ils ont un
côté ils ont petit pécule l écoute
toujours du sperme
et j'ai dit
c'est ce à quoi
nos vieux
hésiter huit ans il se dit géodétique
une sculpturale bazar goût chair de
poule elle était depuis jeudi à quoi ça
être chaud
une apparence alive juin une forte tête
assumer des textes touchants empreinte
de naïveté
amertume potes qui vous embarque au
coeur du rock
oui